hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the finals of the charity cup
it's used of duda versus magnus carlsen
uh this is the first game that we are
showing on already it's a quite uh quite
an amazing one uh magnus defeated duda
yesterday by a margin of two to zero uh
the fourth game wasn't even played so
duda really needs the uh fight back
today in order to force uh tie breaks uh
now what happened in game one
uh i thought maybe it's gonna be a a
quiet game but uh this is anything but
quiet so not spoiling too much let's
dive straight into it the duda has the
white pieces and he opens with e4
magnus goes for his standard sicilian we
have knight to f3 knight to c6 and now
bishop to b5 going for the ross lemonage
medina of attack g6 and now castles we
have bishop to g7 c3 and knight to f6
now putting pressure on the e4 pawn rook
to e1 defending the pawn and now uh
magnus castles we have d4
and d5 now so this is all very standard
stuff nothing new here we have e5
knights to e4 and bishop to e3
uh magnus trades ones here c character c
captures on d4
and the queen to b6 now developing the
queen putting pressure on the bishop and
finally do the traits here we have
captures queen captures and knight f2d2
trying to get rid of this knight because
the e4 square is an amazing square for
carlson's knight and of course duda
wants to get rid of it uh so bishop the
e6 by magnus saying okay if you want to
get rid of it now i don't mind but if
you capture here i'm going to play d
captures on e4 and this pawn will be uh
quite uh
quite a problematic one for whites to
handle for example if knight c3 is we
can attack it okay the rook is attacking
it as well but we can just play rotate
the c8 and now
even sorry
rotate the d8 and now even if you move
the bishop somewhere to try and capture
the pawn let's say you try bishop to g5
it doesn't matter we can just play
bishop captures on e5 and this is now a
problem so white will run into many many
problems guarding this uh so instead
after this bishop to e6 move we have
knight to b3 usually f3 was played here
there are a couple of games in the
database baduda plays knight to b3 and
it is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game saying that i will
play f3 uh but i don't want to play f3
and allow you to capture my knights on
d2 this way i'm going to play f3 and you
have to move your knight away and you
will not be having the e4 square
available for your knight
and magnus now after this knight to b3
move he goes f5
and now f3 going after the knight magnus
attacks the bishop with f4 uh and bishop
back to c1 if you try trading here
captures captures and even rook captures
then after rook a to d8 it's just uh
it's just a very hard position to play
for white he captures bishop captures uh
i mean it's uh
too many lines open for
uh for for for black's pieces so instead
bishop back to c1 and now magnus uh uh
immediately plays rook eight to d8 he
offers the knight here but it would be
extremely dangerous to capture it if you
do the captures then we play this and
i'll look at the pawns i mean that's
just amazing queen attacks the pawn e3
uh best case scenario you will have to
give up this bishop just to survive this
attack so duda prepares it with queen to
e2 and now magnus plays knight to g5 uh
there are some very interesting
variations that start with bishop to h6
but this is an inhuman move we are not
going to discuss that but but we will
discuss queen to b6 because it's super
fun uh point is that um
now it will be a little dangerous for
whites to capture this knight because
the queen is on a very very tricky
square uh so white will just play knight
to a3 and the game would continue to
hear but uh it it's uh i mean it's super
fun the bishop captures on e5 but
there's still this because the of course
the pawn is pinned f captures an e4 and
now bishop captures on d4 with check
knight captures queen captures with
check queen to f2 and now d captures an
e4 so we finally get those two pawns but
now queen captures rook captures uh and
now you have to play knight b5 and this
is the move that gives why the advantage
hence knight to a3 at the start of the
variation but it's quite a lot to see
i'm just showing it uh uh you know i'll
show you guys how fun it is rugby four
attacks the night knight c7 now attacks
the bishop now f3 threatening f2 which
is uh insane rook to f1 and now even
bishop to c4 again harasses the rogue
rook f2 and now we would have something
like rook to d8 maybe going after the d1
square bishop is developed and the game
continues with white having somewhat a
better game and as he defended
successfully uh but magnus plays knight
to g5 and now we have h4 duda pretty
much immediately played this move uh now
saying okay if you go back now uh the
the rook will not be defending the pawn
so i can just pick it up you have to go
either to f7 or here but magnus goes
here he plays knight to e4 and now how
do you continue well f captures on e4 d
captures an e4 and now
well you should not capture this spawn
knight the c3 is the move you have to
play but the duda captured on e4 and the
game is now completely winning for
magnus but it's so crazy even magnus
doesn't see it however you guys see
everything as usual uh feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is pawn to f3
that's the move that wins the game and
now the problem is uh black is
threatening f2 with check and the usual
rook f1 does not help you here the rook
has to stay here guarding the queen so
the only thing you have is queen
captures on c6 but we throw in an
in-between f2 check and after king h2 we
bring another queen into the game uh and
also we've just eliminated this rook and
after queen captures an e6 with czech
white also grabs a piece king the h8
look at your position now it's just
terrible if something like rook f1 rook
to h1 comes uh also the bishop here is
hanging what do you even play bishop d2
okay we can attack the queen but now
queen captures an h4
and now queen to h3 and now rook
captures on d4 even that is in the
position uh just completely completely
dominating if if knight captures on d4
then we just go for bishop captures an
e5 check and you get uh completely
destroyed you're going to play something
like king to g1 and then queen to f2
check king here and this of course will
be checkmate so instead of this uh you
will have to play after rook captures on
d4 you will have to trade queens now
rook captures here with check king to g3
and now rook h5 and it seems like white
has some compensation but not really i
mean this is just too strong the white
king will not survive here let's try
bishop to c3 to guard this pawn we can
simply play rook g5 check king h3 now
rook f1 prevent white from bringing
anything into the game we are
threatening rook to h1 checkmate and if
king h2 is stopping this then rook f2
and now again
a complete annihilation so this is what
happens after f3 but magnus misses it uh
of course we always have to keep in mind
this is a rapid time format players do
not have infinite time to calculate he
played bishop to d5 also makes sense now
puts even more pressure on the g2 pawn
is preparing f3 on the next move uh but
this allows duda not to set up his
defenses uh uh uh uh properly so queen
d3 now magnus advances the pawn to f3
and now bishop to e3 this is how we are
going to guard against the f2 push uh
and now magnus plays f captures on g2
interestingly there is this queen to c8
which is a pretty crazy idea uh white
will have to play bishop to f2 and now
that we're going to have to capture on
g2 so it's a pretty crazy position
because if you go queen to g for now we
can play g3 and defend but it's um you
know just just to show you guys i know
you guys really enjoyed to know
everything that's why i do it but here
magnus played f captures on g2 uh we
have knight one to d two finally duda
connects the rooks and move 22 and now
queen to e6 by magnus the queen is
coming to g4 uh or if dude allows it
even to h3 followed by queen to h1 this
would be game over the situation and the
clock is uh five minutes for duda nine
minutes for magnus and here
we have bishop to f2 the only move that
holds the game for duda is bishop to g5
but after bishop to f2
it's uh it's just a game over however
magnus does not go for this
interestingly rook captures an f2 here
is the move that uh ends the game king
captures queen to g4 and there is
nothing more
for for white to do here it's just a
terrible terrible position the rook is
coming at the f8 with check and uh well
there's simply not a good way for you to
survive this the h4 pawn will be
eliminated once the bishops come into
the game it's just uh
impossible to stop this but magnus
played almost this he started with the
rook and he stopped at a df3 square so
that's the thing because you first start
calculating rook f3
and you like it and then you don't even
look rook captures on f2 uh and this
doesn't work if duda plays properly uh
this should not work for magnus uh so
here duda has to play knight captures on
f3 uh the point is uh he thought that
now magnus wanted to play queen to h3 as
the queen no longer guards this um h3
square threatening queen to h1 checkmate
but now you have bishop g3 that's the
point now you
allow the king to escape via the f2
square and this is the move you have to
find in order to survive now queen
capture send g3 knight uh back to
d2 and now after queen h3 going after
queen to h1 we can play queen e2 if
queen h1 check we play king f2 there's
no way to win this it's just uh it's
just the draw you're going to move the
the queen back we play king back to g1
queen h1 check king of two queen h3 the
position will repeat itself and it will
be a draw however for some reason uh not
for some reason dude i missed that
resource of bishop to g3 that we
mentioned most likely he played queen
captures on f3 and now he uh goes into
this game by grabbing a few pieces for a
queen but it will just not be enough
bishop captures weird knight captures an
f3 queen to h3 now threatening checkmate
knight h2 now magnus of course uh cannot
check my dude's king now but bishop to
h6 and now again if bishop comes here
it's game over uh so rook to e4 stopping
this now comes rook to f8 and you don't
really have a way of stopping rook
captures on f2 whatever you play so
magnus could have already played this
with the other rook but now he he spots
it we have rook 8 to e1 and just rook
captures on f2 if you're wondering why
you can't just move the bishop is
because uh well if the bishop leaves the
defense of the e3 square just bishop to
e3 will finish the game so here rook 8
to e1 now comes to rook captures on f2
simply removing the defender of the
knight here king captures queen captures
now threatening g1 with a double check
uh rook to g1 stopping g1 and now queen
to h3
it's not going to be easy but there's
nothing for for duda to do here rook to
e2 we have a5 now trying to get the
knight to capture to get the knight away
from the defense of the of the d4 pawn
we want to capture this with check and
then pick up this pawn as well but
there's no way to stop this dude that
doesn't capture the knight uh the pawn
with the knight but not just a4 we are
dislodging the knight either way knight
to d2 and now queen captures an h4 king
f1 queen captures sandy for grabbing yet
another pawn knight f3 and now queen to
d5 attacking the knight and the a2 pawn
the position is too open for uh for do
that to set up a proper defense rook g
to f2 now defending the knight queen
captures an a2 now you can even create
some past pawns here uh rook to c2 in
the now we have queen back to d5 we have
broke the c8 check king g7 knocking the
g2 and magnus goes for queen to e4
uh preparing uh queen to g for check so
rook f the c2 doubling up on the c file
but it is insufficient queen g4 check
king f2 bishop to f4 now going after the
pawn there's no way for white to stop
this rook to the c3 and now queen g3
check king to f1 and now bishop captures
on e5 and he was in this position
on mu 43 that young shisht of duda
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the bishop is
captured or or you know whatever
or whatever you play doesn't really
matter we're still gonna capture and yes
you have two rooks against the queen but
you have one pawn magnus has five pawns
and the rooks uh uh are just
not uh not uh
uh able to uh to regroup themselves in
order to do so put some pressure if you
could maybe double them on the seventh
rank quickly or even if you could maybe
attack the pawn the problem is the board
is wide open once the rooks get
disconnected some let's say queen b5
check picks up the rook there's just no
way uh to set up any form of cooperation
so after bishop captures an e5 do the
resigns and the magnus takes the lead uh
after the first game is played which is
not good news for duda he lost the the
match yesterday uh by a two-point margin
and that means that he will have to win
today by a two-point margin uh
in order to adjust the fourth tie breaks
uh
so uh he he will need to win uh at least
the uh
two games now at uh the bonds back or
rather he doesn't have to win with the
same margin i think he just needs to win
today's match uh but it's not to be easy
with magnus already taking the lead so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a lot of stuff was happening
here so we had to explore a few
additional lines uh but as usual i hope
you enjoyed that as well uh i would like
to thank dripper cyberclub nft uh
blueberry friends twitter rob rob
antonio sharp fate and david charnot for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
charity cup
finals until it finishes so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day